how are you guys doing today
wonderful thank you for asking uh thank
uh thank you for doing this
um my biggest regret while watching the
movie was that i wasn't watching it with
a full theater of people
to share in the experience um it has to
be a little bit
like for you guys you make a movie like
this it's a group ensemble
you it there's tons of fun stuff and you
want to watch it with a big crowd
is it a little like painful for you guys
like knowing that it's so hard to
in this environment right now that you
know most people aren't going to see it
with a full crowd
i saw it with like just my nearest and
dearest and
really really really dug it and it
helped with the creepiness of it and
um i i laughed out loud regardless so
i have hope that not too much of the
experience is lost but of course movie
theaters are magic
and feeling the energy like the act
there's
actual energy in the space with other
people
yes of course i wish people could
experience it that way i wish i could
experience it that way
and i also i wish i could experience it
with the rest of my cast
and yeah amen to that you know
uh before jumping into the specifics of
the film uh and congratulations on it i
got some other
uh other types of questions so let's get
started on some of those real fast
um what tv series for each of you would
you like to guest star on
mine are on different ends of the
spectrum um
one is the marvelous mrs mizel and then
the other is
ozark because i really want to just like
play a garbage person you know
you want to be a garbage person i'm on
miss maisel or on
ozark yeah i want to just be like the
jewish
comedian that didn't make it on mrs
meisel
no i thought you're going to say the
jewish community that didn't make it in
the ozarks and then you want to be an
ozark person in
in marvelous you know like like
marvelous like you better pay me or
i'll take your boat you know or switch
it
yeah yeah i want to i want to switch it
how did i can't understand
genre or tone of any of the shows that
i'm on
we cross pollinate you know that's
that's what i want i mean me i just i
want to i want to be
jon snow but in east town with mayor you
know what i mean
you know
um what movie or movies do you guys
think you've seen the most
and i don't mean during the pandemic i
mean life i didn't grow up
with a lot of vhs tapes unlike you
joshie
who like has all of the trivia um
so i just had beethoven and i watched it
every day
maybe twice a day maybe three times a
day
it's it's deep actually if you really
look into it it's about like
the trapped animal in all of us who
wants to be a good boy like don't we all
want to be the good boy
i hadn't thought of it like that yeah
the animal within all like the
werewolf's like the
saint bernard within saint bernards
within
saint bernards within
what scary movie did you see too early
in life
that messed you up chucky
oh oh good one yeah oh my god
because you keep living around dolls
like it's not like you're gonna stop
getting toys
and you're like is this thing gonna come
to life it's not like they're not gonna
be there at
every sleepover you can get them out of
your own room you can't get them out of
your friend's rooms
uh stephen king's cat's eye like
speaking of like being in a child's
bedroom like
just like watching young drew barrymore
deal with the troll that came through
the hole in her wall but like ideally
the cat
rescues her and i love i love a cat um
that was that was intense i think that
was like my the first one that really
messed me up what do you guys collect
if anything milana do you ever have
you not really i got a lot of plans but
like only because
it's the pandemic
i i want to be one of those um i mean
actually like like
like you stephen i want to be one of
those like you know
like like a cool nerd that has like the
stuff like i want to get like
old ghostbusters toys like a dark man
comic book with like you know with like
like framed and like a cool like cool
legos and have like an office
that's just like my excuse to sort of
like live in my childhood a little bit
um but i don't have this i'm literally
talking to you from my bedroom
i haven't i have nothing um
do you remember what it was for each of
you that
made you interested in the entertainment
industry like said i kind of want to do
that like
i want to do that like whether it be a
performance whether it be a movie
what was there something when you you
know do you remember what got you
excited about it
i have been kind of like like acting
since i was a kid
just for the money and because it's fun
like i did barbie commercials as a kid
um because we're like immigrants and
we're like i don't know she's she talks
too much put in front of a camera like
we didn't know what we were doing
but um but switching to comedy and
becoming like an improviser
was i think for me like when i started
to actually
want to do this and had have a career at
it
and i went to ucb on franklin
in hollywood and i saw brian gallivan
perform and if you don't know who he is
you should look him up he does this like
sassy gay best friend character online
but he does a million things and he's
brilliant
at all of them but anyway the suggestion
from the audience
was hollywood bowl which is like an
am the theater is it an amphitheater
it's a it's a giant
theater here in l.a and uh
he started the scene with i'm eating
breakfast out of my hollywood bowl
and it was just a scene about a guy who
had a bowl from every city
and the way that the entire
show was structured around this
ridiculous concept
and and like became perfectly a
absurdist play i was like whatever
however they're pulling those rabbits
out of hats i want to learn how to do
that
so uh that that changed the game for me
for sure
wow that's so that you when you said
used to be reminded me like yeah i could
be like oh i saw batman i was like i
want to do that you know fight crime
um i uh i did go to ucb on 22nd street
like the old theater in new york and
would like wait on the lines for the
asscat shows like the late night shows
were like you know
mike myers might pop up or
you know amy poehler and the original
ucb cast and stuff
and i think that was probably when i was
like not only do i already knew i wanted
to like act and perform or at least like
be a part of that community but that i
like wanted to do
like i wanted to be one of them i wanted
to like wear like thrift store
jackets and like um you know skechers
and have fun friends and like get bar
food after and like
nerd out about comedy um
i did and once i started taking classes
and stuff i felt very much out of the
clique
but uh that was an inspiring time
because
you know you'd see the shows like late
night and then you like watch
you know elf and like the performers
would pop up in movies like that and be
like
i saw them sunday you know um
it was a cool thing that and you know
lee straussberg you know just like
love his work
for uh for both of you um when
was the last time a director said to you
um or josh when was the last time you
said to someone i really need you to
make this
in one take oh i told molana and sam
that was that is literally the last time
i
i told them that i was like we're just
going to push in we have so much time
you got to make this
this scene work i was about to give
something away but um yeah it was like
set to a song
we had to really limit our coverage it
was all just to push in and they nailed
it
okay so it actually like hey i know you
said only one take but can i do it one
more time please please please
and then everyone's like okay everyone
says like oh she's begging
they all say like it's a chorus like
okay
like an audience last thing i promise
before we jump into the movie
uh one of you uh acted on
er as a little kid and i
couldn't believe when i read that i was
like wait what
so i really need to know what that
experience was like and do you
yeah exactly and do you remember what
that experience was like
doing that oh yeah yeah
george clooney was there you don't
forget that [ __ ] um
i i think it was season one
i was like i was an eight-year-old
playing a six-year-old like i'm always
playing young you know
and um and
i this is my i don't know i'm doing a
tic tac now i don't know
um and i i remember
whenever i would get on set as a kid i
would get so energized because i was so
happy to be there that my mom would have
to like
calm me down and i would just walk
around
warner brothers i got to be on a studio
a lot just
crazy as a kid so fun and also it's like
where looney tunes is like
the animaniacs are there and urkels
being filled next door
and george clooney's playing basketball
with urkel
so yes i have so many vivid memories of
that time and um
i played a little russian girl with aids
that julian margulies wanted to adopt
but she couldn't she had a sorted path
and um yeah it was a it was a really
really
beautiful happy memory for me i remember
inviting george clooney over my house
and being like my mom's not a good cook
but she will try if you want to hold her
just under the bus that is incredible
and he just like like looked up like he
did like the head things he's like
sure you know the killer tomatoes i
remember
he would call me kiddo and i was like
that's the best that's the best word to
call a kid
you know like everything he did i was
just like smitten
everyone was how could you not be i
appreciate you sharing that story
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you guys today for people that have
not seen the trailer
not familiar with the with the movie um
josh how have you been describing
the film to people uh knives out with a
werewolf that is very good
i mean it's just the fastest way i could
possibly do i mean i could get into the
plot about how you know
a small town of oddballs gets snowed in
at a local lodge and then gets picked
off one by one with the creature lurking
in the dark but it's like not
that simple as well there's a lot going
on you know so
it's a who done it with teeth by the way
that that's totally accurate
one of the things that i found
interesting uh was that i believe you
filmed this
in february of 2020 which is
right as right before kovid shut down
the world
so i am curious i don't know how long
your shooting schedule was but when you
were making the movie
were you like talk were you aware of
kovid was it was it entering that sort
of thing like are we going to get shut
down
what's going on with the world do you
remember molana like were we talking we
were by the end like the last week for
sure right
we were talking about it no before the
last week i think because the last week
was when we were on the stage and by
that point i was already like going up
to crafty and the medic
and being like hey so uh these
berries have just been sitting out all
day and uh there's a virus lurking in
there can we cover the berries
oh okay miss okay you're crazy
[Laughter]
i remember being at we were all staying
at a at a hotel together
a lot of us were and um i remember
sam and i like ordering bags of beans to
the house to like our houses back in l.a
just because we're like wait so food
gonna be skip what systems are going to
shut down
and i remember you saying josh like yeah
they're talking about people getting
sick but they're not talking about
people who are surviving this
oh why are you like trying to be an
optimist about coven
oh my god my sister who's a musician um
she came back from tour in a little city
called
wuhan and was like there's something
going on
i thought she probably she was patient
zero she was like there's something
going on
um i got you n95s walkie-talkies and a
life straw and like started buying a
bunch of flour and i was like
rachel you're crazy and she's like no i
just came from there
it's like contagion so she was back like
when we were like doing having the berry
talk
so she came back before like it hit she
was like i just left
um so she was the matt damon really in
that situation um
and she was like here's all this stuff
and i was like whatever rachel were fine
my mom
insisted on sending me um on the plane
home with clorox wipes in a ziploc bag
so i like to wipe down stuff a week
later i'm like okay rachel would
would you mind like sending and sending
all that stuff that you had
you know you purchased um and uh you
were right you know i had to go back to
my my big sister and was like you were
right there
there was something something occurring
that something was a reason to sit at
home for 16 and a half months
and now we're here oh uh
the lesson that i took away from this
entire conversation is the big sister
was always right
oh oh yeah absolutely yeah she's also a
great musician check out rachel yamagata
you know she's uh
oh my goodness i geeked out when i met
her because i was her biggest fan in
in in college she was like all i
listened to and then i got to meet her
at our little family slash cast and crew
dinner that that josh hosted at hit oh
josh
josh's family hosted at josh's family's
house
and she's a very special person and it
was a family affair
her song doesn't scare me but i i don't
think her songs are
in worlds within right now where also
that is just ace of base and savage
guard and she had her
moment with the um you know with the uh
the tale of emasculation and gender
competition
um and now we now it's time to give
savage garden a chance you know
they might make it uh josh how much did
you debate
putting yourself in the movie as one of
the why didn't you
i'm just curious why didn't you put
yourself in the film as one of the leads
or you know what i mean
i do know what you mean i mean it's you
know 12 people i could do it with three
people and myself i'd self-directed
quite a bit i know melania knows that
world very well too like it's
it's not bad when you're when it's like
three you um and you can kind of suggest
to whatnot when there's 12
and especially when you're working with
like some of the like the
comedy and just film television and like
broadway
superheroes from wayne duvall to milana
and
cheyenne harvey salmon it goes on and on
i was like i probably should take a step
back there was one moment when my
manager was like
maybe you should you know be one of the
one of the 12 and i was like um
f off that is you're asking for a
meltdown nightmare i was so grateful to
be as
tricky as it was to kind of juggle
everything it was it was nice to come
home to you know my
cabin in the middle of the woods and
like make a hot toddy and be exhausted
not having uh to memorize lines and
wrangle
but i will say i was close to being the
voice on the radio and i'll make this a
collider exclusive
the voice on the radio in finn's car
is rhea perlman
oh look at that pearlman is in uh
werewolves within
i i like that thank you she's great
she's great she was like super down to
do it originally
it was like it was supposed to be a dude
right was it always
it was like yeah maybe it was gonna be
kind of like you know like uh
tony robbins or like masculine
um maybe even joe rogan type uh and then
it turned into
no let's make it kind of uh uh i don't
know i just like
the idea of kind of an uh a motivational
speaker but a rap
a raya comp and um i just straight up
asked her said i've known her daughter
lucy for a long time we went to summer
camp together years ago and i was like
do you think she might be into
it and yeah she did so raya proma she's
in werewolves within
she rounds out the cast i i love it um
for both of you
i am curious about filming those big
group scenes
because i would imagine that it's just a
it's
not it's for for josh i'm sure it's very
stressful when you're trying to get
these takes
with all these people but at the same
time i would imagine as a performer
it is [ __ ] awesome working with all
these people
and also trying not to laugh and you
know and actually you know and make it
with the limited takes i'm sure you guys
are doing so
for each of you can you talk about
working with those the big group
shots
well for most of the movie we only had
one camera
and then for some of the bigger group
shots we had
two cameras i think it was like for only
maybe two
it was like 48 hours yeah um
so we just really had to be on our
a-game and all know our timing and all
that
but as you know i i really like
always just relied on josh to to do that
and to keep us on our a game and he was
really good at
never showing us him sweat
um even though he's so sweaty he's like
such a
wet man um josh whitman
and uh mr whitman director whitman
um but uh we for me
the the big group stuff was fun because
we all got to be together and we all
loved each other
it was kind of yeah that was kind of
incredible they all
everybody somehow got along sorry we're
gonna say
i was just gonna i was gonna say i think
it's this moment though another
collider exclusive uh which one of you
wants to reveal
who ruined the most takes from like
laughing
or you know breaking i i think i ruined
the most takes from laughing or breaking
i
i i honestly i don't think there was
anyone who is unfocused
i i honestly looking back on i don't
think there's one i mean
maybe maybe like milan like milana's
fairy like
on like it's just she's i'm kind of
i don't know it was it's not like
reckless it's just like
i think you were like very like hazard
you know what i mean like
yeah it was like very hap yeah it was
like half half but it was also like you
know
i don't know like you get very you know
what i mean violent i don't know
yeah i was like yeah violent yeah yeah
what was the question like
i was gonna say something about who
ruined the most kicks but josh i am can
you talk a little bit though
about directing when you have all these
people you know especially sometimes in
in the cabin when it's just everyone um
you know what was it like directing
those scenes
and uh and trying to keep it all
together
you have to be communicative with your
actors you know john battam wrote a
whole book about it you can't
hide and you need to show everybody that
you have everyone taken care of and
there is a
fine balance despite the fact that i'm
like a cancer and an
open nerve a cancerian by the way i'm
not like a walking
anyway um i mean josh is like he's
you know he's like a kid and uh
so it was um it was partially
uh being quite firm about these tableau
compositions
where okay guys this scene is about
say finn entering the room
and everyone has their own separate
business in the background
let's just see what it looks like if
finn enters he stops right here and then
we see
um each character kind of responding and
closing in so that by the end we have
you know we go from a tableau to z
tableau
and so you every actor is quite savvy
they know where the camera is i said
let's just try that and then everyone
just sort of feels it out you adjust
accordingly
and then you end up with with a
wonderful composition shot which often
we had the opportunity
really to only do two angles you know
two takes each
um but everyone was just so proficient
um in
just terms of blocking and their own
kind of instincts and the like it
it really wasn't it wasn't difficult
again like milan was mentioning the
difficult thing was the limited
technology we you know it's it might be
a bigger budget than
you know my first film but it was still
a 12-person cast with one camera so you
had to be
had to be clever i'm always fascinated
about the editing process because
uh that's where the film is the final
rewrite it's where the film comes
together
can you talk a little bit about what it
was like editing the the film
and who you trusted for honest feedback
yeah
i was editing the movie
well that was the thing is that milana
had the avid set up at her house so like
we were on
evercast you know we did it remotely and
milan is like i have editing actually
myself
so i was doing it now my
uh no sorry jack melania you did you
started like the first cut that you did
was like all crossfades
do you want to talk about that like well
yeah
and all me um i just felt like i know
what people want
and it's so so we had to kind of pair
it's not that we had to pare that down
it was just that again you know
exactly tell the story and so that's
where the other characters came
in separate of that so to what what
moana was able to do is basically
take hours of footage and just whittle
it down to every one of her scenes and
everything else was on the cutting
floor and it was it was a small
nightmare but we ended up with uh bo
burnham's inside
check it out now on netflix and it's a
real it's a real treat
well it was uh uh brett bachman who
edited
mandy and is now doing toxic avenger for
legendary we were lucky enough to have
him
do werewolves within he is so
technically
proficient so um wonderful with sound
has such a wonderful sense of humor he
was he
he had such wonderful swings and from
from the get-go i think it was like that
that
that wonderful thing you want in an
editor where it wasn't just um
piecing the thing together uh
but it was also challenging me to
um to find the best way to present
narrative you know so whenever there was
kind of a a
task or mandate from the producers hey
maybe we'll introduce this you know
reordering of scenes or
flashback scenes and the like i mean he
he never missed a beat
and always was there to make incredible
suggestions and
some to some degree i was just kind of
like oh brett but it's gonna be so much
work to like go down that route even
though i know it's smarter and he'd be
like but you should you should get on
your iphone and like
do some adr and we'll see how the you
know scene pieces together in an even
smarter way i mean
he was just uh yeah hopefully never do a
project
without him um he was the he was the
wonderful sort of um the new eyes on the
project then of course we had test
screenings you know we did that
over zoom which was which was weird but
helpful
really you guys tested it over zoom
we had links that would expire and then
um
some folks would watch them they only
had a window to watch them and then we'd
we'd hop on zoom and do like a panel and
it was uh it was
it was cool we did it a few times and
quite useful
uh and so it i'm curious because the
thing about this movie is
you're it's a it's a whodunit so you're
obviously as you're watching you're
trying to figure out okay well who
what what exactly is going on so one of
the things i would imagine is
you know when you when you're presenting
information during the movie
how much do you want to present how much
are you giving away how much you're
trying to pull back
so i'm i am curious if that changed at
all in the edit in terms of oh wait we
went too
far we have to pull this back or we need
to give more
you know what i mean there were some
conversations like that i mean the
wonderful thing about the movie and the
thing i was trying to be a barometer for
is that everybody
had their kind of agatha christie moment
like everybody has their moment when
it's like that person's a suspect like
they raised their eyebrow a certain way
and turned into the shadows
um but uh yeah there was a bit of that
calibration but it really you know
mishna's
script um her last name is wolf by the
way our screenwriter mr wolfe she um
no joke uh she had this thing so tightly
tightly wrapped and tightly executed
just from the get-go that it
it made it easy to piece the thing
together
um and then it just kind of became about
like how fun can we make it how can we
make it not
you know too too trod and yes you know a
bit of the thrill ride something that
might feel a bit like
clue
how early do you want to see an edit
when you're involved in something
do you want to see like a rough cut so
you can sort of like whisper to the
director
you know i remember take two i did a
different thing with my smile
i think it's a little better or do you
want to sort of wait until it's done
and do you know what i mean i want to
see it right away
i want to see everything right away but
i don't think i would tell the director
what takes to use
because i just trust josh more than i
trust myself
that sometimes help you know um
with understanding tone i've definitely
like jumped into
tv shows that were whole seasons and
felt like oh if i could have just i
could have just watched
it then i would have unders you know so
sometimes it's just helpful to
see what the director is thinking early
on or what the editor's thinking early
on
but it's um it's really just for my own
neuroses and psychosis it's not really
to make the movie better i don't think
that's
something better than a director can for
both of you i've spoken to
over the many many years of running
collider spoken to a lot of
actors and they some of them absolutely
cannot watch themselves on screen
i mean they go to a premiere and they
walk right out of the theater
for both of you can you watch yourselves
on screen or does it tweak you out
well we both direct act and
have edited ourselves for about a decade
that's true that's true but melania can
you
even when you direct yourself well do
you you probably look beyond
all of the psychosis stuff and just like
what technically is working like how do
you what how do you look
yeah well i actually i don't have any of
the like
um the nervousness when i'm directing
myself because
i i think i just have um a calmer
understanding or also knowing that i
have a say over the edit
in some cases not in all cases um makes
me
less afraid so i don't feel the need to
to control it that much i'm more about
exploring when i'm directing myself
um but you know just watching this movie
i
i felt this is this is a not okay thing
to say
but i felt proud of myself i felt like i
i um i yeah i love the movie and i love
the character
so um so it was a real joy to watch but
yes i've also watched myself
in things and totally cringed and wish
i could turn back time yeah i think i'm
exactly
similar when i'm when i'm self-directing
whether it was like old videos for
college humor playing like
marty mcfly or um or even with
scare me i could somehow look through
the
um the icky stuff and feel okay and i
think part of that is because yeah you
there's an element of well i know i have
full control
to sort of you know says that's a good
angle or it's a good delivery or you
know you can kind of support yourself
while also not wasting your you know
your gaffer's time or whatever
um but uh i think 99.9
of the time when i do something for
someone else unless i'm wearing like a
sizeable beard and like contact lenses i
have a really hard time
watching it like i've done projects
where
you know someone will send me a rough
cut just wanted excitedly you know
director like i'm excited to sneak this
thing down i just
i can't even you know i can't even think
about clicking that old video
obviously you made this on a budget and
you have snow in this movie
uh you're depicting snow and the entire
time i'm watching i'm like wow
it must have been a pain in the ass with
continuity to try to pull this off
you know with the amount of snow falling
in the scene or whatever
so was that going through your head at
all like do we really want snow to be
falling
you know with the continuity issues or
were you sort of like embracing it
i mean from my standpoint i was like
ubisoft's got this they got a big enough
checkbook it's like you know yeah we
were fighting global warming like you
know one day the lawn would be
uh resplendently snowfall and then the
next it would be green
in january february um but uh we had
wonderful uh vfx artists that were that
honestly seamlessly transitioned you
know we had we did have practical snow
starch flakes um and the like snow
blankets
um and uh in some cases real snow and it
somehow blended beautifully
um yeah i don't know how
we did it but it was i mean an amazing
wardrobe team who would re-starch us
and then clean us off and then put fresh
starch on us and then clean us off
i mean there are so many
talented meticulous people working on
this
or caring about meticulous tiny little
details um
that make it all look seamless
yeah rachel and kelsey and david taber
our wardrobe
like shout out to them in the biggest
way but that that was the biggest win
like melania called it out is that the
fact that
like we had the practical snow on
shoulders and
hair that is what transitioned us so
successfully in and out of scenes and i
was just like oh my god if
there were stuff i was looking at the
edit words like if we didn't have that
small little sprinkle it would have it
would have taken you out of it to a
degree
so one of the things about this it's
based on a vr game by ubisoft
um can you can you talk a little bit
about how involved is ubisoft on
something like this
which is are they really involved in the
edit are they controlling a lot of stuff
or is it sort of like can you sort of
talk about their involvement
in the movie if if at all the script
came out of the ubisoft
uh women's film and television
fellowship so mishnah wolfe script was
developed through that wonderful
fellowship program under the um the
watchful eye of margaret boykin who is
our
incredible producer who on a daily basis
i text her and say you have spoiled
any incoming opportunity i have with how
wonderfully you've treated us
um they were very involved i mean it was
their baby it's a new initiative they
did
tread filmic territory before with like
assassin's creed but they were like too
big we want to try something
a little smaller let's go to blumhouse
route let's like write the check and
just do this kind of smaller genre thing
so they were very involved but they you
know the wonderful thing was from the
get-go even though it was based on this
video game
and i was the one to be like what easter
eggs what do we have what do we owe you
what do we owe the fans what do we have
to like
imbue in the library or in the wardrobe
and jason altman i think was the one to
be like you don't know us anything just
like make it good
like make a good movie and i was like
understood understood
you know for each of you guys what are
you
most excited for people to see uh to
watch the movie
you know for people to experience sam
ooh that's a good one uh melania vine
troop
reactor has their moment um i think that
for me it's just that you know coming
out of the trauma and the continued
trauma
of what this past not just 16 and a half
months
have been and are but four years have
been i'm excited for people to forget
90 minutes of uh uh or forget for
90 minutes um all of the
pain they may have endured um and just
like go for a ride i think we need fun
movies right now and for us to like go
to a dark theater with our friends and
just like laugh
a hundred percent uh for both of you
guys um
i always like asking about future stuff
uh for each of you like what can you
tease about what's coming up
or things you want to pursue are we
getting like a live action squirrel girl
can you like break this news here like
what's happening are you gonna be in the
marvel
universe can you just just be straight
with us
yeah okay so here's the collider
exclusive
ready so four more
[Laughter]
just like a red a red light yeah
just moving around my face both of you
direct
so i am curious if you could get the
financing
for anything what would you make
and why everything that i think about
making i think about what i could do on
a small budget
first so i i almost like haven't even
allowed myself to
think like that but what a fun way to
think i think it's time for a horror
hero i think
dark man has been dormant too long and i
would love to
play in that space again mainly because
i think there's a fun
relevant uh genre tale about a scarred
hero living in the dark that can only
fight crime lives with the uh
the sort of shame of his like deformity
and yet um
uh takes on like the appearance of other
individuals by like creating masks out
of it
with a 3d printer and liam neeson killed
that role i think it would be so fun to
revisit dark man today
um because it's like kind of a you know
bit of a phantom of the opera thing like
you're
here's here's someone who might not feel
like they deserve
love that has been kind of like going
mad in the dark
um but also like shoot it as fun and
interesting as raymie did
um just like go a little bit further
with it like i think if they've done
deadpool like a funny violent
kind of marvel i think there's something
cool to revisit
a fun sweeping but also like um
uh irreverent and clumsy horror hero
i think there's there's something there
um
that's just my honest you know it's me
being honest
sincerely thank you so much for talking
to me
and i really hope this is a huge hit for
you guys and that
you know audiences respond to it and
that
as i said it's just a huge hit